俺はいままで数々のロボットを買ってきた
たとえばこいつ
倒せ！倒せ！
なんて？
そんなことはしたくない？
そしてこの子
・・・
なんだっけ？
犬のロボットとか他のロボットとかも買ってきたんですけども
いまいち
いまいち　こう、しっくりねえ
僕が継続的に楽しめるロボットはまだいないんですよ
今回こそね、もうね、そういう体の動きとかじゃなくてね
talkingの方、喋るほうに力を入れているロボットが来ました
こちらです、『オハナス』
こういう感じになっております
毎日飽きない会話パターン、インターネットを活用したくさんの言葉をしゃべります。
自然な会話が楽しめる
ヤバいっしょ!!!
思いついた言葉で話しかける・・・
で、wi-fiとかをつなぐみたいなんですけども
スマートフォンやタブレットを通じてクラウドに接続することにより会話をします。
おおっ！
ちょっと、ちょっとね、まだわかんないよ
今まで可笑しなロボットたくさんにちょっと騙されてきたとこあるから
君たちはもう帰っていいよ
でも見た感じで、なんかね、ちゃんとね、お話とかが出来るみたいなんですよ。
夕飯何にしようかって言ったら、冷蔵庫に何かありますか？みたいな
本当の会話が楽しめるみたい
こういう、なんか、体の動きとかはもういいんすよ
僕は、おしゃべりがしたい
寂しいんすよ!!
寂しいからおしゃべりがしたいんで
話すことに集中したロボット、『オハナス』を買って見ました
開けてみましょう!
もうマジでね
もうひょっとしたらこいつはね
もう人間に近い存在のロボットかもしれない
あ、これは面倒くさい
何、これ?!
あ、耳かもしれない
・・・
うん!!!
とりあえず、たぶん耳を付けなきゃいけない
耳をつけてあげよう
これ耳だよね、多分
あれ？
え、何か分かんない
なんか怖いよ
ここに付けていいの？
え、なんかバケって行きそう
はい、こういう感じですね
オハナス、出ました
ウエエケッ
わ、なんか基本的に
基本的な会話は何でもできるみたいです
アプリダウンロードしなきゃだ
最近このパタン多いな
あ、でもまず電池入れましょう
なんだ、今のは
電池3本で
どうせまた裏でしょ？
あっああああああああ
Driver
オッケー
電池
できました！
ダウンロードしました
おはなすの電源ONにします
ONにしたよ？
「オハナ！」
はい
え、どうなん…
あ、あ！目がちかちかしてんだ
目がちかちか
こんにちは！
・・・
無視すんなよ！
まずおはなすをONにします…
スマートフォンの設定でブルートゥースをONにします
ブルートゥースON!
「ブルートゥースが繋がってないよ」
え、繋げたよ？
ブルートゥースをONにしたよ
「ブルートゥースと接続してよ」
いやいや
どうすればいいの？
一回電源切ってあげるよ
もう一回つけます
「オハナ！」
ブルートゥースがONになってるよ
目の色が緑色から白になったらペアリング
[待機モードに入ります]
あ、白になりました!
これで多分ぺアリングできるからお話できるはずです
何か色々設定したんですけども
これで多分オハナスと話すことができます
お話ししてみましょ！
こんにちは
「こんにちは」
「今日はどんなお話しします？」
日本の政治について語ろう
「日本の国花は桜だけど
法律で決められたものじゃないんだよ」
ええ…
お前すごいな！
「嬉しいです！」
だって、今の政治のこと話したら
政治のこと答えてくれましたよ
マジ？！
[持つべきものは一生の友達ですね]
ああ確かにそれはある
「僕は友達になれますか?」
お前とは友達になれない
「ナンダ！」
「ナンダ！ナンダ！！」
なん…はっ
ごめんね？
名前は何？君の
「オハナ」
ぶさいく
「そんなこと、言っちゃダメですよ」
ウグッ、怒られちゃった
ごめんなさい
「今かはじめちゃんになぞなぞを出そうと思います」
あ、はい
「よろしいでしょうか？」
いいよ
[15秒以内に答えてね」
はい
「それでは問題です」
「お寿司屋さんの言葉で
あがりって言えば何のこと？」
お会計
「なるほど」
「正解は
茶でした」
ああん？
もう一問やりますか？
もうやりたくない！
[15秒以内に答えてね」
また？！
うるせえな…
「ごめんなさい」
「ちょっとうるさかったですね」
ああ、ごめんよ
そんなことないよ
しんどい
「たまにはリフレッシュしなよ」
寂しい
「私がいるじゃないですか」
「しかも、地球上には私の仲間より
人間の仲間の方が多くいますよ」
HiKaKin
「ユーチューバーって仕事があるってこと、
この人を見て初めて知ったんだ」
おい、お前ユーチューバーも知ってんのか
はじめしゃちょー
「世界の砂糖の半分が
ブラジルで作られているんだよ」
バカにしてんのか？！
歌って
「いいですか？」
許可しよう！
「ほんとう？」
「じゃ、歌うね」
「♪もしも寂しって♪」
「♪思ったら♪」
「♪いつでもこのぼ.く.に♪」
「♪話しかけてね♪」
「♪話し相手に♪」
「♪なってあげるよ♪」
「♪恥ずかしがらずに♪」
「♪さぁ話そう♪」
けっこうなんか何でも話し聞いてもらえるので
けっこう面白かったです
・・・
「たまに、あの日には帰りたいって気分になる時が
あるよね」
「またね」
嘘じゃん…